another hangout super excited to be here
I have a special guest Sean from video
influencers and Sean reach out to me
want to interview me for his show
basically helping entrepreneurs get
started on YouTube become an influencer
turn into a full time job and I said hey
that's an awesome idea why don't we turn
it into a hangout some irons can learn
too and meet him so this is going to be
Sean interviewing me but first Sean
maybe a quick intro for my audience as
to who you are what you're all about
where people can find you and then take
it away like you normally do your shows
man
sounds good Evan well thank you so much
for being here pump to be live on your
platform and yeah my name's Sean kennel
with video influencers the co-founder
with a guy named Benji and yeah we do
exactly that we help people build their
influence income and impact with online
video heavy focus on YouTube but so much
is happening with video right now
snapchat periscope Facebook video so
many things and I know that you know
that and so that's what we're doing over
there youtube-dot-com forward-slash
video influencers plural and a lot of
cool stuff happening over there cool
let's do it ready to jump in there all
right I'm gonna try to hit your intro
here and and we'll just go for it cakes
I've got your stats they're incredible
they're amazing you're amazing you ready
here we go okay so uh hey what's up
everybody sean here with video
influencers helping you build your
influence income and impact with online
video and today i'm here with Evan
Carmichael and if you never heard about
him before he's actually listed I have
some stats here by Forbes as one of the
top 40 social media marketing talents in
the top 100 great leadership speakers by
next conference listed him is that he's
an entrepreneur expert his YouTube
channel has over a quarter million
subscribers with over 30 million views
and he runs Evan Carmichael comm a
popular website that's all about helping
entrepreneurs succeed how's it going
Evan I'm good man thanks for having me
yeah thanks so much for being here and
maybe just to kind of kick it off for
our audience I'd love to hear just kind
about your story I mean obviously you're
you're doing a lot of stuff and you're
helping entrepreneurs and heavily on
online video but how did you get to
where you
are today and what's kind of been your
progression just from like a video a
YouTube point of view I mean we could go
all the way back I know you you started
a business and sold it at a young age
and you've done some other things but
yeah I just got have a nutshell of your
progression and getting into online
video sure it's a quick overview I had a
biotech software company was nineteen
sucked at the start wanted to quit
eventually turned it around sold it when
I was 22 I started my website just as a
way to give back and help entrepreneurs
to hopefully not face the struggles and
the you know feeling of self-worth that
I had the negative feelings when I was
getting started and not eventually
evolved into a video platform just
because I much rather them in front of a
camera then then right and so that's how
I started my youtube channel just
answering people's questions and it
eventually evolved from there that's
awesome and so you kind of noticed that
trend of online video early on I mean I
noticed this channel started in 2008
right I have no idea so that sounds
about right
so you've been doing this for a long
time and and obviously with a lot of
success but one of my questions would be
if you were to start over today because
what's kind of been and what have you
seen as far as shift and change over the
years and obviously you've built this
influence a lot of people who watch our
channel there that's what they're trying
to do they're trying to of course
increase their audience reach more
people
but things have kind of shifted and
changed what are some of what have you
seen is the progression and if you were
to start over today what do you think
you do differently that's a great
question I don't know how much I pay
attention to trends and shifts I may not
be the trend and ships guy I make videos
that I'm excited about and so it's
always a lot of the videos that I made
on my channel now I make for me if you
watch the top 10 series you're in
special series I made for me because I
want to be surrounded by those ideas
every day create an environment for
greatness and I'm fortunate that other
people want to share in that too
I probably making them even if nobody
cared about them I think what I might
would I do differently it's always a
tough question I don't really look in
the rearview mirror that much I think
one of the things that really helped
was the practice I think people just
give up too soon I've got over 3,000
videos on my channel most of them are
public a lot of them aren't just me
practicing and practicing and practicing
and getting better and honing the craft
and I think too many people you know
they made 20 videos and they quit
because they feel like I'm not getting
good enough like it takes time you know
like 20 videos is nothing and and I
think too many people compare themselves
they might compare themselves to where
I'm at now and you're comparing like
your starts at somebody else's middle
and it's not a fair comparison
if I had to change one thing I think
that the person that really made a huge
impact on me was my media coach that I
got through my agent and I maybe wish
that I had coaching and training a
little bit earlier in my journey made a
huge shift in how I presented on video
and just being more comfortable being
myself and turning up if you look at my
old videos the content is still quality
but my energy is really boring and very
introverted and anyway so she had a huge
impact on me and I almost didn't say yes
there working with her so that was I'm
glad I did that but that was a couple
years in so working with them sooner may
have been a benefit I guess but I still
I feel like every mistake that I've made
it just led me to where I am now
and so I try not to live too much with
regrets and like I wish it did that
better I'm just more focused on where
I'm going I love it that's awesome now
just in a short synopsis for people who
haven't checked out your channel yet
because you got incredible content there
but what cut your publishing like a ton
of videos what is your just kind of
schedule and what's coming out in your
channel right now so we three videos a
day the morning series is typically
called in spresso and that's a quick
shot of inspiration and motivation to
help you grow your business it's a short
video there's somebody famous saying
something and then I'll have a comment
on it typically the lunchtime series
comes out at noon Eastern and it's kind
of more practical answering people's
questions and then the evening series is
8 o'clock Eastern is longer videos
typically famous entrepreneur top 10
lessons of success that you could learn
from - you know sit down and spend 30
minutes or 20 minutes with Steve Jobs or
Warren Buffett and kind of hope some of
their pixie dust rubs off on you and you
can apply to your business I love it but
I know that probably our audience fell
out of their chair dropped their iPhone
while they were eating their Chipotle
when they heard three videos a day a lot
of people know you need to be consistent
on YouTube but that's like a whole
nother level of publishing content and
I've studied your work and you know that
you definitely kind of have a team and
sort of a system what has been what are
some of your tips and even your strategy
and your thinking in that because that's
it's a different approach than the
average kind of solopreneur youtuber
mentality sure and that's kind of the
the the path from being a part-timer to
eventually becoming full-time and it's
unfair to try to keep up with my
schedule because I do have a team now
we've got six people who work on a
YouTube channel from when I started I
was doing a video a week and I think
being consistent has been a hallmark of
my channel if you go back for years I've
been consistent and that's me getting
better and practicing but you should do
one video a week because I was doing
everything I was filming I was editing I
was writing the script I was on camera I
was doing the titles in the description
and doing the promisor everything and
think like you relate to that as a solo
entrepreneur a solo youtuber you're
doing everything the biggest shift that
helped me grow was when I got an editor
and I hired an editor part-time and that
allowed me to move from making one video
a week to one video a day and that was
insane for me and then eventually hired
more people I hired a researcher however
second editor might need to hire a third
editor and slowly increase from one
video dated - and now the three I think
it's understanding what you're really
great at and what you want to get better
at you know I'm not a great editor I
have no interest either in learning how
to be an editor my best time is spent
being in front of the camera and telling
stories and given advice and not doing
all the other stuff and so as an
entrepreneur the more time you can spend
doing the things that you want to be one
of the best in the world that the more
your business will grow the challenges
you're usually spending like five to ten
percent of you
time on that stuff that you want to be
great at and the rest spent on all the
other crap that's involved in running
the channel and running a business and
so I I mean I was hustling I was
grinding about to doing one video a week
but as soon as I could afford to hire
somebody part-time I put it into an
editor so that I could focus on the
content that is a super great tip and
let's shift into talking just about
monetization and I know also from your
work that you have a totally different
approach than that than a lot of people
so you know our audience is one of the
things were trying to figure out is how
to build our income and sometimes the
thinking is like okay so I need to get a
lot of views and get YouTube ads but
obviously you have a much more dynamic
and strategic approach and so what are
kind of your tips and your progression
with online video and you know turning
that creativity into a career part-time
and then full time yeah if you look at
any of the successful youtubers the
people have made have made a name for
themselves the Adsense is not the
primary source of income for any of them
and I'm sure the other people we've
interviewed you got some great stuff
when your channel said similar things I
sense is great it could be a good place
to get started especially if you don't
have you know you know a good at sales
you don't want to reach out to people
it's an automatic kind of source of
income but it doesn't pay very well some
niches pay better than others I'm
fortunate to be in a niche that does pay
better than average but if you're in a
you know cooking niche or you know doing
recipes and it's just insanely how you
can get tons of views and it's still
insanely hard because nobody's
advertising in there so for me that was
how I guess I started but I quickly
tried to branch out into making other
deals so I think I encourage
entrepreneurs to be an expert in their
in their field so for me I do a lot of
brand deals with companies who are
trying to reach entrepreneurs today I
came back from Dallas office and we did
a periscope and live hangout there
answering people's questions and I work
with Dell for a couple of years now so
brand deals are definitely a big part of
what I do but it's all towards the long
term I think too many entrepreneurs too
many youtubers thinking like how do I
make
a thousand bucks next week where my
focus is all about building a
relationship and doing longer-term
projects so I got a book deal with a
sizable advance with penguin Random
House in advance that most well first of
all most first-time authors don't get
any kind of advance let alone what I got
but it's because of my YouTube audience
that I got that because I spend a lot of
time making videos because I'm in the
comments and responding to people and
taking requests and doing live streams
and so that's the bigger opportunity is
working with brands doing a book deal
you can go down the route of selling
gear like lots of people want me to make
believe hoodies they want this they want
the t-shirts it's something that I'm
working on a rather partner with
somebody on that then make it all myself
but a lot of when you have a tension
there's a lot of opportunities that open
up people want that attention and so
focused first on building the community
and getting the attention and income
opportunities open up much more than I
ever thought I never even did this to
make money now it's now being a youtuber
is a is a is a career path when I
started it wasn't it was just trying to
share so I sense it's definitely great
place to get started but it's not what
you're gonna make a ton of money with
for most people what if we turn that
super practical and get into the
trenches with that advice we'll just if
we could use us as a case study for
we're about a year old and were
approaching 30,000 subscribers so we're
still kind of like the new launch phase
I feel like but if we were to use kind
of us as an example that maybe
entrepreneurs could relate to that are
just kind of starting out what are just
the first couple steps in thinking to
cultivating those relationships if
you're in you know using us for an
example that sort of size I think it so
I started closing my first brand deal
around your side so I want to say was 25
30 thousand subscribers somewhere in
there I think it depends on your skill
set I am NOT a great salesperson I'm not
I'm not a good networker I'm very
introverted it doesn't come across and
like these interviews and stuff but I'm
very introverted you know I'm not the
selling guy if something comes and it's
easier to sell but I'm not every time I
tried to do outreach every see
time it never worked I never got a deal
I couldn't convince the guy to go with
me and it always would be in such a weak
position because I'm going to them and
they don't even know I exist and I'm one
of many people pitching them and the
same experience in working I look at a
look at platforms like famebit where you
can get brands to sponsor you and you're
one of a thousand people pitching the
same brand and they beat you down on
price and I'm getting paid multiples of
what these guys are paying and there's
no competition and so the way that I do
it based on my strengths have been more
of a marketer than a Salesman is in the
community in that because I have
awareness my business model is build up
as much noise as possible kick up as
much dust in my industry as possible
because there are people at these brands
whose full-time job it is to identify
people like me like you in those niches
and so the first company that came to me
the first brand newly ever closed with
was Xerox and they wanted me to come to
their event for small business and talk
to their senior vice president of small
business about how they can sell the
entrepreneurs better I never thought I
would get corporate gigs I thought I'm
kind of screwed in this industry because
most corporate gigs you speaking events
I would tell people go start your own
business like why would Dell want to
hire me to come speak to their people
I'm gonna send them all off away so I
thought I would never get any speaking
opportunities but I still did all this
stuff because I love it and so for me
the secret sauce is the the community
right I'm heavily engaged in the
community I believe every YouTube
comment that gets left on the channel
needs to get a response and that was me
for a long time doing it now my wife
helps me and I have someone on my team
who helps me too so we get a couple
hundred comments a day everybody's still
getting responses and because we have
such a imprint I guess on the community
brands pay attention and they take
notice and so for you guys it would just
be turning up the hustle like keep
making quality content take feedback
from the audience and there's
that are getting back leave a comment on
every comment that comes in when I'm a
guest on other people's channels who
just came off of Tim Schmoyer channel
doing an interview and I went in and I
responded to every comment on Tim's
video where Tim wasn't even respond to
every comment on Tim's video and every
other guest didn't bother leaving a
comment I'm sitting there
commenting on everybody even though I
have hundreds on my own channel to
respond to to like that's my secret
sauce is getting the community going and
kicking up as much noise as possible so
like if I'm you I would try to be doing
this with every interview that I do try
to get a live stream on their channel so
people know about you and then I would
be afterwards in the comments responding
to everybody who writes in so that they
know about you they feel the love like
Shawn cares about me and I go back like
I would go back every month and see if
there's any new comments on that video
and you'll start building up the
traction audience and if you get the
audience and awareness you'll get the
brands coming to you I love it I love it
that's incredible now let's flip to
branding really quick and and I know you
got a lot of tips on this for you know
you're sitting in front of a wall with
branding it's got the paper airplane
it's on a hoodie it's got the paper
airplane and and that's even matching
your vibe there it of course you know
goes across your whole channel what is
kind of some of your thinking and for
video influencers that about the power
of good branding about figuring that out
and then about executing on the
practical side of that with all of the
things to do these days all the social
media all the different things yeah I
think I think it's important for people
to know what you stand for and I think
it really helps separate yourself from
everybody else so I believe everybody
has one word that they got to figure out
what it is for them and that'll help you
build a business and live a life more on
purpose than just being reactionary for
me it's believed I believe in in people
I believe in myself and I want to spread
more believe out there and that came
from my parents more than anything else
the paper airplane comes from the
entrepreneur is like this airplane
trying to lift off kind of go and do
something big and it's paper because you
don't have a
resources and you're going against the
odds it's not a 747 you're launching
with it's it's flimsy and you know
likely break but somehow you make it
that represents believed to me one of
the biggest things when I started with
believe was I started a test on my
youtube channel
I thought believe was too big too crazy
words you know lots of people who are
they used it before Who am I to use
believe and I made a video the best
video that I had on my channel up until
that point was the story of Chris
Gardner from pursuit of happiness who
went from homeless to being a
millionaire and I got a hundred thousand
views in a year like no that's it's a
good video man that's my best video I'm
feeling pumped and excited then we made
a video on believe in what it meant and
we got a hundred thousand views in a
month and now that video is over a
million views and is still one of the
most popular videos on the channel and
so I think clarity to what you stand for
helps helps people tie themselves to you
more because they believe in your
mission much more than just the content
so you know video influencers I get a
sense from your names to what you're
trying to do but what's like what's the
mission behind what you're doing why is
it so important to you if that came out
more front and center I would I would
love you more right like I would want to
do more to help you if I line with that
mission and it also helps you attract
not just not just subscribers who love
that but but brains and you know
customers and people who will pay you in
media who love that message where if you
don't have a message and you're one of
thirty YouTube channels or a thousand
YouTube channels all doing the exact
same thing right like we need another
gaming channel or another beauty channel
or another X channel right if you're
just same as everybody else forget it
but if you are leading with a purpose
and a mission something that's powerful
people connect to that immediately
separates you from everybody else
so it's massively important I love that
well what are your maybe just a few
quick tips on how to master your message
did you have clarity from the very start
of your YouTube channel or was there a
progression and even if you eventually
at some point had to
you know pull Claire together someone's
like okay I want to collect all my
thoughts and and all my stuff and I do
want to distill this down what are maybe
a few tips to to get to that point yeah
I think the the biggest thing that
helped me was trying to think of it from
a perspective of an individual me as a
person and not just a marketing thing so
at the start I was I had like
entrepreneurial tips and wisdom or
something and then over 20 million
entrepreneurs helped and Counting kind
of like the McDonald's signs that you
see you know entrepreneurs deserve help
or something like all this stuff that
looked good from a marketing point of
view but didn't really touch anybody
because it didn't touch me and so it
came down to Who am I what are my what's
my main core value what do I believe in
as a human being
forget about business what do I believe
in as a person who are the you know what
do i what do i look for you know in my
wife and in my friends like if you are
not like this you can't be in my circle
and then take the personal part and
bring it to your business and so for me
believe is is me like I'm I'll be
believing in people whether they're
entrepreneurs are not encouraging them
to do better it's just part of my DNA
and so that shift helped me quickly find
it where before I was always trying to
think from a marketing point of view
what do I want to do and then you plow
through everything like the logo
represents believe to me like what's it
what's a symbol of belief well it's a
paper plane taking off against the wind
everything becomes much clearer every
every partnership every video I make
everything becomes a lot clearer in my
youtube channel but the rest of my
business and my life because I know who
I am or what I stand for and so that
just shift and approach to make it about
me and not about the marketing side
really help powerful principles thank
you now let's briefly talk about you
mentioned not you mentioned trends a
little bit and thinking about the
progression of trends but I'm curious
you're of course as an entrepreneur
you're big on innovation and trying to
always stay current what are some of
your strategies and thinking as well as
the question would be like what do you
see as trends right now what are you
what you're thinking about staying
innovative do you worry that your
contents gonna get in a rut and then
what are some of the things that you're
paying attention to that you think
entrepreneurs the video influencers
should be paying attention to I think
the bigger concern for me and for
entrepreneurs is is I'm not worried
about my content getting into a rut I'm
worried about me get into a rut I think
it's so easy for entrepreneurs the Box
themselves in I think it's so easy for
you know you just start a YouTube
channel and for a year you're off
killing it and you know doing this new
innovative stuff and then because that's
what made you successful that's what you
keep doing but you get more more bored
about doing the same thing over and over
and over again and the longer you keep
on that path the harder it is to deviate
and go do something else and you're
gonna get bored and frustrated and not
feel like you're growing and you left
your job to become a youtuber or an
entrepreneur to get out of the box and
you just created a box for yourself and
so for me it's understanding that as I
evolve as a person to my interest
changed I bring that to my youtube
channel and I bring new content that I'm
excited about launching I look at other
people's channels I try to model things
that I like a lot of times is not in my
shower like I have the most subscribers
of anybody in my sharra for
entrepreneurs there's nobody else who
has more so I look to other places where
I get ideas that I can then bring into
to my channel but I think more than
anything else because you've been trying
to follow a trend and everybody says hey
do this this is a great trend to be part
of but if you're not excited about it
you're not passionate about it like it's
not gonna work out
it's those you know Entrepreneur
Magazine's top 10 industries that you
have to get into this year and great and
you try all them and you fail at all of
them because you never really have a
passion for it so for me the benchmark
is always am I getting stale am i bored
of my content if I am then I need to
change it and fortunately every time I
have my audience comes along with me and
they get excited - awesome awesome well
we are in the lightning round
so give me an interpretation with sound
effects and your arms of what lightening
looks like was Boosh alright here we go
at the lightning round of course these
are fast questions but as much time as
you need lightning around three two one
coffee or tea coffee talking or texting
talking
would you rather here we go never use
social media sites again or never watch
another movie or TV show again never
that's a tough one never you never watch
a movie I could never watch a movie you
can get it on social media ripped anyway
that's true
person you trust most with a secret my
wife if influencers could watch only one
video on your channel which video would
you recommend the let's go with the
Steve Jobs top ten rules what was the
last thing that you grabbed out of the
fridge my lunch what was it
salad and chicken and grapes fantastic
would you rather have unlimited
international first-class tickets or
never have to pay for food again at
restaurants these a these are some
questions let's go with restaurants nice
favorite place in the whole world
Toronto biggest pet peeve mediocrity
movie every influencer should watch jobs
last song that she had a repeat oh it's
a sped-up version of where's it let me I
have my YouTube thing up here nightcore
stand by you awesome well look it up
yeah well link it up in the
if you could only have one thing during
a zombie apocalypse one item what would
it be
witness Dom bees fear
I don't think hobbies don't have a fear
you don't have to kill a zombie with
there's a lot of options I mean we've
seen such a variety of options but you
only get one thing one thing I'll have
my wife she'll kill all the zombies for
me okay she's peers don't mess with Nina
okay just a couple more your favorite
YouTube channel right now let's go with
I want to see my own I mean that sounds
egotistical but I love my mean I love my
content I'll go with Gary Vaynerchuk
Gary Vaynerchuk
yeah he was on yours right he was on
yours recently yeah we just posted
yesterday
nice idea when you're watching this okay
one book that every influencer should
read 4-hour workweek and one podcast
that every influencer should listen to I
don't listen to podcasts do you have a
podcast no we don't okay I was gonna say
video influencer podcast videos youtube
channel there you go the audio don't you
have to watch there's a cool one called
the not-so corporate podcast is an
entrepreneur named mark Drager who runs
a that's not bad not so not so corporate
podcast there you go it's my choice I
love it I love it okay and it ended with
the lightning round sound effect in our
emotions again lightning round concluded
okay just a couple more questions you've
studied the greats
and what are some of the common traits
to master when it comes specifically to
building your influence I think I think
one having a sense of purpose like I
want to do something for a greater
reason if you want if you want to
influence others they have to feel like
they are a part
something so what's the greater thing
that they're gonna be a part of you can
see people with no background raise an
army because they they have a powerful
belief and mission that they were trying
to accomplish you can know all the
people in the world but if you don't
have anything powerful to for them to
follow they're not gonna care so that's
one and then to actually taking action
on it I think a lot of people have this
thing in their head that they like to do
but they're stuck in their job or
whatever you know they have a crappy
environment they're doing a nine-to-five
they don't believe in themselves enough
they're not watching video influencers
enough you know and so they don't
actually take action on their thing it's
not about your personality you don't
have to be a type a you don't have to be
egotistical you don't have to have
millions of dollars it's really just
about having an idea and then taking
action and then not quitting when it
gets hard that's it brilliant brilliant
okay so what are some of your projects
of course we'll link everything up in
this show notes of this episode of the
YouTube description to your stuff but
where the main please places people can
find you what do you have coming up you
know just type in Evan Carmichael you'll
find me whatever your pleasure if you
want if you're a web person or a YouTube
person I'm spending most of my time on
my youtube channel and in my books I got
a book coming up with penguin Random
House in December and I'm heads down and
finishing the writing and will soon be
in marketing mode once once that's up so
those two projects take up a good chunk
of my time so it'll be available for
purchase in December yeah did you
release the title yet not yet okay is it
about entrepreneurship yeah okay I
didn't live it it's not it's not a
cookbook no you do not want to read a
cookbook by Evan Carmichael it makes
sense okay sandwiches Evan land the
plane for us which is one kind of final
word of encouragement or tips whatever
is on your heart for influencers
watching to get out there and crush it I
think it's it's just a matter of keeping
going
I think surround yourself with resources
that help you wake up every day and want
to take some kind of
chin I think entrepreneurs and youtubers
just give up too soon too quickly
you're not seeing results you're not
where you thought you'd be we said
overly ambitious goals and I'm gonna hit
a thousand subscribers by the end of the
year and you're stuck at 20 that happens
keep going like listen to to video
influencers watch the shows like
surround yourself with resources build a
network around you just it's
consistently keeping going don't lose
the fire don't lose the passion when it
gets tough awesome Evan thank you so
much I love it thanks for having me man
for being on the show
and it still running you can leave it
running
yeah those that are live here's here's
what we do we're gonna shoot the intro
now and I'm just gonna try to say it
what were the three most powerful things
you said I have to see the three most
powerful things you guys do I'm just
writing them down I have to what was
your favorite part I don't know what
were your favorite point what audience
what are your favorite points
I don't know there you go oh yeah I
guess a few minutes so we can hit Q&A
let me just let me just go for it okay
I'm gonna say you have you talked about
thinking bigger about brand deals
clarifying your message and just give me
one other thing don't quit that's what I
ended with and going oh and how to keep
going when things get hard okay there we
go it's just that's all me but we were
looking at the camera they can kind of
see you whatever three two one in this
video I interview Evan Carmichael and he
talks about how to think bigger about
brand deals clarify your message and how
to not quit when things get hard coming
up that was I want to watch an episode
right that said it's at first six or
seven seconds or 10 seconds very
important so we edit that to the
beginning all right we um whatever you
want to do yeah okay we got a couple
minutes I gotta hop on a call but if you
guys have a quick question leave in the
comments first one came in from a cus I
hope I pronounced that right what's the
single most important key to success
bonus oh this is okay oh you go this is
for probably you and me you
both of us man I want people to know to
hear your thoughts - man is good
I think this yeah I think the single
most important key to success is it's
kind of like you know taking a card out
of what gary vaynerchuk's been saying
but I think self-awareness
I think being you you know don't die
die a copy you know being original
there's only one you and it could be so
tempting to just look around and try to
copy somebody else and be somebody else
but the hardest thing to do I think it's
discover your true strengths and then
really execute on that despite what's
popular I love it for me passion men do
do what you love
I mean it's tied to it you'll be
different if you do what you love you
got it if you lose interest in something
move on to something else you can't be
great at something that you are just
apathetic about you got to be all in and
explore until you find the thing that
makes you come alive and do that reviews
dude what message would you suggest for
a tech channel what you think John
that's good okay I actually have a tech
channel it's called think media TV and I
mean after this interview it has me
rethinking everything but the tagline
for that channel is just helping you
move further faster in media but it's
not necessarily tapping into a why so
I'd love to hear your thoughts I think
why tech I mean that's my heart behind
that or we do tech reviews video reviews
audio gear reviews to help people go
further faster in media so anyways
that's taken because that's my my
tagline right but but so I mean what are
your thoughts like putting a why around
something that is so practical yeah for
me it doesn't matter the industry for me
it comes down to your value so believe I
could apply to anything I could ply to
any it could be it could be in the tech
industry it could be in the I'm gonna
set a professional chair throwing league
believe could be the message there
whatever I do instantly gets more
believe and so it comes back to who you
are as a person and you bring that
message to your business again we talked
about that on the show that's the single
most important thing that helped me was
transition from not just thinking
marketing but Who am I is a human being
and then I bring that to any business
I'm involved in that's powerful I think
you should actually start it professor
you know chair throwing yeah that's what
I'm talking believe believe chair
throwing Lee Raymond where can I be in
one year starting from zero subs depends
on the niche I would say to be fair
because some things if you start a prank
channel and you're really good at it and
they're really funny
you could be huge but that's gonna be
the nature of some things that go viral
like that if you start a bass can
underwater basket-weaving channel you
might be able to grow a solid audience
of people passionate about that
but it's never gonna grow as big so that
I think it's the first thing and then I
think there's two absolute ways for you
to grow your channel that I think are
the best one people don't really mention
one is collabs every YouTube channel
that shares tips is that that's gonna
help you grow so the mote the more you
can do of those it's gonna be grow but
the second one I believe is ranking
videos youtube SEO video SEO meaning if
you can build a library of videos that
show up in search in your niche then it
creates views why you snooze so whatever
your niche is if people type in how to
do underwater basket-weaving and you
show up in the top search results then
that video is going to grow an audience
of people interested in your niche 24/7
365 depending on how big the search is
so really figuring out how to rank
videos of course we talked about that on
her channel more but those would be the
two strategies for us we did ten
thousand and ten months but I mean just
just kind of you know we'd had a lot of
connections a lot of collabs and ranking
videos those are our two strategies
views while you snooze I like that one
Raymond doesn't follow the same it's
awesome to hear us say his name so this
is for you Raymond
yeah for me I'm not so attached to the
number like my goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs but I love the process you
know I wouldn't worry so ok so I want to
be a tent I want a model Sean I wanted
to be a ten thousand subs in a month in
a year and then I get to a year and I
have 29 subscribers right like that can
happen it doesn't mean you're a failure
but if you are only chasing the numbers
you're going to do videos that you're
not super excited about just to drive
those numbers up you've got to love the
videos that you're making and you
will the audience will come and it may
not be a huge audience depends on the
niche like Sean said but don't be so
attached like I there's way more things
to worry about
then how many subscribers are gonna have
in a year um Simeon signed me on I'm
hopefully not killing his names
how can we get the idea I want to make
something good I want to grind but I
don't have the idea
semion what idea for a business for a
youtube channel or should we just go
general Evan uh let's go YouTube channel
the topic is YouTube so let's go go with
that I mean it's tied to business but
what do you think I want to start a
channel I want to be a youtuber but I
don't know what I'm gonna talk about I
think what you want to do is you want to
create a framework and you want to draw
three circles that are intersecting in
the first circle you want to write the
word passion and the second one you want
to write profitability and then the
third one you want to write proficiency
and so it's at the intersection of what
you're most passionate about but I would
say that passions not enough because I'm
I'm I'm passionate about music and
singing but if I had a YouTube channel
where I was singing it would be
unsuccessful and probably with all the
coaching in the world I will probably
never be able to pull that one off so
it's something that I do in the shower
not something that I do in YouTube so
it's the intersection of your passion of
course your proficiency so you have a
level of skill but then also
profitability now if you just want to
have a hobby channel that's fine but you
have to say is there a market could
there be a community around this in this
sense of like is there a proven path
here of course you could trailblaze but
at the intersection of those three
things now you've got very good clarity
I'm really passionate about this it's
something I'm good at and obscure that
and it's something that I could help
people and there's kind of a market for
it so I could monetize it therefore it's
possible to turn my creativity into a
career in that area for me I would I
would just say explore man like you got
to find the thing that makes you come
alive I'm much more on the passion the
passion circle for me is the big circle
I feel like you can overcome limitations
in proficiency and and profitability and
turn find a way to turn it into
something but if you don't know what
you're passionate about just explore
like explore explore explore explore try
different things and don't be afraid to
give up something that's good to go for
something that's great and something
that's better
we are crunched on the time but I want
to get last question from Donald because
Donald Man is a hardcore viewer watches
every video he's saying that's me I only
have 30 subscribers in a year I need to
get more consistent what do you
recommend quick tips for Donald quick
tips Donald for consistency I think
batching is one of your most powerful
things when it comes to consistency I am
a lot of times we'll shoot if we want to
do one video a week shoot four videos in
a day and then you've got a month's
worth of content and so figuring out how
to batch and group like tasks so then
you are not having to turn the lights on
and do everything batching is super
powerful for consistency I would say I
love I mean I love batching too I would
add to that make the time man
consistency you just got to make the
time you block it off you put Wednesdays
is my video day and you spend a day
doing videos and it has to become a
priority
that's it that's nothing you're a lazy
person man because there are other
things that you turn up on and you over
deliver on and you got to just treat
your YouTube channel as a priority just
like anything else like why is it not
important enough for you to block off
five hours on a Wednesday to focus on
YouTube channel you got to find a way to
do it man until it becomes that
important a priority this is not gonna
happen and we're with you bro come on
man you got to make it happen I want to
see these videos going out every week
okay we are tight on time Shawn for
people who want to find you I'm gonna
link if you're setting everything but
what's that let's use whether to reach
you if they're watching this thing's a
man another guy is dropping knowledge
they could definitely reach out to me
personally on Twitter at Shawn Cannell
SCA n last name CA and n e ll at Shawn
kennel I respond to one I'd like a
hundred percent of tweets I mean I do I
try my hardest happy to help people with
online video questions there and then
youtube-dot-com forward-slash video
influencers Channel all about helping
you build your income impact and
influence with online video love it
thank you thank you guys for watching
thank you shrunk at the time you seem to
believe and we'll see you all soon thank
you having
you